zum abschluss dieser tollen
jahresrückblick sendung noch mal unsere
besten momente aber und das ist mehr als
sechs oder momente moment damit keine
outtakes barbara titanic ist kurz
dagegen
[Musik]
ich wollte meine liebe und herzlich
willkommen zur place to be stars &
stories ich bin natalie mario götze und
nach angaben der du hast verkackt ihr
aussehen so leone
anschließend konnte man verfolgen wie an
als ich in sachen haare und make-up
mutig durch die paparazzi vor
anschließend konnte man verfolgen diana
sich in die sich anna ganz verrückt und
eine sache wo hat an mutig durch die
farbpalette tastete festival lesen ein
anschließend ganz kommen wir als
nächstes zu klimaaktivisten luisa
neubauer habgier einsatz richtig gesagt
mama katie diesen ihre community das
gesamte jahr über verschiedene links am
bahn momente hat die klappe ich mach das
jetzt anders
okay okay kann ich sicherlich ordentlich
hin danach so jetzt nimm dich über den
reden wir denn jetzt
[Musik]
achtung nämlich zu recht wie amazon.com
hat weisen sam zum größten
amerikanischen schachspieler benny ging
es für diesen schauspieler kurz wenn ich
gestorben bin aber das gefühl von
besorgnis kämpft ricardo simonetti der
moderator in unserer inspiration starken
schlag es geht um behinderten jungen
mann
was wird ihm ihr nach alles aus ihrer
zeit im heim erzählt hat das sehen wir
gleich jetzt erst mal das medley update
cara und grinsen bei mir hat er erzählt
warum der fragt man es für ihn besuchen
kommt für dubai wurde diese woche ein
traumpaar youtube-star bibi und auch ihr
mann julian die haben also schon und mal
und haben wir haben die promis
gebrachten kontakt xxx die herzogin von
sussex sagte sache ja das leben
die herzogin von 20 nein da geht es mit
einem teenie gericht gestritten
und weiter geht's mit einem teenager
weiter geht's mit einem team von coach
nun über mode tipps bis hin zu von bot
das wird heute leider glauben über so
auch schon wenige tage später machten
verschiedene djs wie dj mag die marke im
januar gab lena gercke ihre erste
schwangerschaft begangen bekannt weil du
hier so bezahlt wird so von esolar das
wird wieso nicht hardy corona the
challenge of social media aus bei der
fans zu dem track tanzen stark der war
richtig fest
wie geht es mit job lass es einfach lass
es freut mich für dich und gut ist so ja
ich habe zwar viel mit den händen machen
ja ich dachte auch so was ist los
gebärdensprache ist aber nicht für die
zuschauer haben inzwischen ein kind
genau
genau das war nicht unbedingt einfacher
und genauer
ja mag okay nee das wäre ich mich ich
war ich mache noch mal ich will nicht ja
genau sagen
das macht mit diesem jahr vom place to
be stars & stories mit natalie und mir
ich hoffe ihr hattet spaß wir sehen uns
nächstes jahr wieder
und wenn ihr noch mehr von uns haben
wollt dann hört im podcast place to be
podcast überall wo es podcast gibt mit
ganz tollen gästen bis nächstes jahr
guten rutsch und gesund
[Musik]
[Applaus]